wealth distribution is completely out of
line today in fact people have talked to
me about the minimum wage and I've
shocked people and said maybe what we
ought to have is a maximum wage if
somebody makes a hundred million dollars
a year that's not enough what could you
possibly need if you made a hundred
million dollars every year and the case
in point the walton family right that
owns Walmart each member of that family
makes billions of dollars a year and yet
their employees have to be government
subsidized by we the taxpayers because
they don't earn enough to not be
subsidized something is gravely wrong
with that my position on that is if you
work a 40-hour workweek I don't give a
damn what the job is if you work 40
hours a week you should get paid enough
money so that you do not require any
government subsidy at all
now how you determine that or what that
number is we got to figure it out but to
me if you work 40 hours a week shinin
shoes
washing dishes whatever that might be
you should earn a living to where we the
government and the taxpayers should not
have to be subsidizing you
you